hier soir le chef de l'état faisait
montre d'une connaissance
particulièrement active dans le domaine
du rock and roll était ce le fruit de
son goût de ses fiches
toujours est il qu'il n'a pas hésité à
annoncer qu'il y avait en france 35
mille groupe de rock and roll une
véritable lame de fond avec le problème
que connaissent tous les jeunes
orchestres où et comment répéter c'est
donc pour eux la chasse au local ici un
hangar où l'un garage ce qui ne fait pas
toujours la sphère des voisins ou de la
municipalité comme en témoigne
l'histoire que nous raconte maintenant
jean jacques dufour depuis cinq ans ce
parking dans lequel nous descendons et
le centre opérationnel durant parisien
malheureusement la mélodie en sous-sol
est en train de se transformer en
symphonie inachevée
pourtant au niveau - 4 les rockeurs se
croyait à l'abri des tracasseries tu en
fouille est caché sous terre on essaie
de faire sa seconde saison sa personne
expulsée ils crient en choeur touche pas
à mon box le problème majeur d'un groupe
de rock s'est trouvé un local pour
répéter nous ici on a pas mal de
matériel je veux dire c'est bien pour
répéter nous on ne demande pas on s'en
fout d'être au quatrième sous sol sous
des tonnes de béton du mot qu'on peut
jouer notre musique nous c'est tout ce
moment à l'origine ces boks devait
recevoir des voitures mais ils ont
finalement été louée 1000 francs par
mois il y a cinq ans à des musiciens
aujourd'hui l'office hlm de la ville de
paris à qui appartient l'immeuble a
demandé au gérant monsieur bataille de
faire procéder à une expulsion en raison
du non respect de certaines clauses de
sécurité attenant à la réglementation
des parkings ventilation issues de
secours installations électriques etc
évidemment disent les musiciens c'est
vrai mais était ce bien à nous de faire
ces travaux
les deux
j'en entends parler quatrième sous sol
on commence à entendre la musique
seulement à partir du troisième
strictement aucun problème de
sonorisation fait peur aux locataires
n'ont fait pas peur aux locataires ça se
passe depuis cinq ans d'une cordiale
indifférence il s'intéresse pas à mon
stress pas eu
on n'a jamais eu strictement aucun
problème avec même avec les gens qui
gardent leur voiture au dessus qu'on a
jamais trop
lundi dernier le ministre de la culture
effectué une rapide visite dans ce parti
n'est apporté son soutien à une
initiative qui faisait dire à la ville
de paris qu'elle regrettait
l'exploitation politique de cette
affaire est la préoccupation n'est pas
du tout de faire une bataille politique
nos préoccupations et l'est de défendre
le droit pour des jeunes de pouvoir se
réunir se retrouver et faire de belles
choses
soucieux d'équilibré afin d'éviter une
pause note politique je demandais au
maire du 19e de m'accorder ni interviews
il préférait me parler au téléphone
tout cela dépend maintenant d'une
décision de justice la ville de paris
n'est pas juridiquement en cause dans ce
contentieux mais monsieur tiberi
président de l'office hlm et moi même
nous sommes prêts at il déclaré à
étudier les conditions qui permettraient
de régler cette affaire au mieux et
espérons le car dans rocker il y a aussi
le mot que